If the question is,
uh.
Would I have joined the National Front
by Jean- Le Pen?
Maybe not.
That's it,
all political movements have a history,
but all political movements are changing
and.
And I prefer to think of two thousand and thirty,
at two thousand and forty,
at deux-mille-cinquante,
rather than playing politics
in the, the,
the mirror.
So,
I think today,
uh,
we are 1 great popular movement,
patriot,
uh,
where the oceans come from a very different appearance.
Uh. You look
very popular territories in the North of France,
the workers who for a long time have sinned to the left,
had their hearts on the left,
vote for the communist party,
vote today in favor of the Rassemblement National.
You look,
uh, in the south,
in large cities,
in the historical territories of the right,
Today,
this right no longer exists.
And these orphans of the right
vote for the National Rally.
So I also believe in 1 form of,
of exceeding
and. And.
And I think this,
this,
this opposition between the left and the right
that we have tried to maintain for years
to precisely register in 1 balancing act
between the left and the right,
has probably lived.
And it is perhaps moreover
one of the only points of agreement that we are
with Emmanuel Macron